where major league baseball along with
joe biden stacey abrams
they have struck out yet again
completely embarrassed themselves
and because of joe biden leading these
lies the mlb
is now moving the all-star game from
atlanta georgia to denver colorado
a state would get this just for irony
similar but in truth more restrictive
voting laws
than the law just passed in the state of
georgia for example
georgia has 17 days of in-person early
voting
including two optional sundays to vote
colorado
they only have 15. both states allow
no excuse vote by mail and oh do you
know colorado also has a voter id
requirement just like georgia so
what message is major league baseball
sending to fulton and cobb counties in
georgia
and the good people of georgia joe biden
stacey abrams
major league baseball delta coca-cola
they all lied about georgia's election
laws
and that has now cost the people of
georgia almost 100 million dollars in
revenue
every person in georgia should be
furious with biden
abrams major league baseball and frankly
almost 200 finalist corporations
for amplifying these lies now joe biden
played the race card it's plain and
simple
innocent people have now suffered the
worst part of this
is biden's home state of delaware they
have
far more restrictive laws on voting and
here's what the weak and the frail and
cognitively struggling joe biden
told our own peter ducey earlier today
when asked about his own boycott calls
take a look the masters golf tournament
should be moved
out of georgia i think that's up to
the masters look
you know um
it is reassuring to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are
well welcome back to the show
joe biden needs to apologize to the
people of georgia
to the georgia legislature needs to take
responsibilities for his actions
and frankly his lack of applying the
same standards all across the board
because
what he has done here what he is doing
is absolutely
disgusting and completely dishonest why
isn't
anybody in the media mob but for peter
ducey
asked him about this and frankly asked
him to apologize
he is straight up lying completely
disregarding the facts
and what this law does and does not do
this law in georgia does not limit
early voting it actually expands it it
does not reduce voting hours
it actually gives voters more
flexibility to decide
when they want to vote they even add a
saturday to voting
and yes you're allowed to bring food and
water while you wait in line
so no joe there is nothing in this law
that resembles jim crow 2.0
and you should be ashamed of yourself
for hurting an innocent state and
innocent people playing the race card
using that kind of language
joe biden needs to be asked why he never
lifted a finger
to change his own home state's more
restrictive laws
why have you only singled out georgia
joe are you going to pressure the pga to
end the masters this week that
tournament
uh joey supporting the beijing olympics
the winter olympics
not far off next year 2022 that's right
china
how fair are the voting rights across uh
in china
and do you support the u.s pulling out
of the beijing
beijing olympics and by the way the
state of new york where
mlb is headquartered yeah they have more
restricting voting
voting laws than georgia has new york
new york only has nine days of early
voting
they require a valid excuse if you want
to vote absentee
unlike georgia which has no excuse
absentee voting and what about joe's
home state of delaware
oh delaware has none no in-person
early voting georgia 17 days of
in-person early voting
delaware delaware requires specific
excuses if you want to vote absentee
in georgia anyone can vote absentee in
delaware there are no ballot drop boxes
anywhere
in georgia drop boxes they're still
available
and one box per county that is required
so are new york and delaware are they
pushing jim crow laws
too joe and when are their boycotts
coming
joe biden is absolutely positively lying
to the american people and is hurting
innocent people in the state of georgia
about the georgia law law and about
voter id
it is not racist it is not restrictive
it is not an undue burden for voters
it is a practical and necessary step
to ensure that georgians or residents of
any state for that matter
can have confidence and integrity in
their election results
it's that simple and you know uh where
else
joe needs to show an id yeah joe by the
way
if anyone in this country wants to visit
you at that white house you live in in
washington the one you're sleeping in
right now
yeah you need a picture id to get into
the white house as a visitor to see
you you want to go to the u.s capitol
visit the people's house
you want to meet your congressman
congresswoman yep you need a
picture id you want to go to the
democratic national convention
you need one there too get on an
airplane you need one
buy a house apply for a mortgage rent an
apartment
yep you need some picture id you want to
buy a
six pack of beer or alcohol or
cigarettes or jewel pods
or apply for food stamps or apply for a
job or apply for welfare programs
apply for medicare medicaid apply for
unemployment
drive by rent a car purchase a gun adopt
a pet
rent a hotel room pick up a prescription
donate blood
and even get allegra d and other cold
medicine at your pharmacy
and the list goes on and on in every
case you need a picture id so
ask yourself why is the mlb
all of these corporate ceos why are they
so outraged by the election integrity
reforms
but are also totally willing to do
business with china
delta coke 200 companies we're going to
be watching
we want to see if you sponsor the
beijing olympics
joe we want to see if you pull america
out of the olympics
why are they all silent on very real
human rights abuses in beijing
so will joe pull the u.s out of the 2022
beijing winter olympic games is delta is
coke are they going to sponsor the
olympics in china
what corporations will sponsor the
olympics in china because don't forget
in china there is ongoing mass detention
of the uyghur muslims that's happening
today
the assault and imprisonment of
pro-democracy protesters
we've all been watching what's been
happening in hong kong an all-out attack
against basic human rights in tibet
is all of that okay major league
baseball joe is it okay with you
well apparently a lot of you did a huge
deal with china for major league
baseball
you're taking china's money did you
question china about their human rights
abuses
and what about the beijing olympics in
2022
we're now learning tonight that the u.s
is in fact considering a boycott of the
2022 games
i guess peter ducey raised some
legitimate questions today
will these woke corporations are they
going to follow a soup
suit in fact if there is there going to
be a boycott there
because what is clear is that joe biden
stacey abrams
the mlb commissioner are all willing
participants in what is now a
massive lie propaganda disinformation
campaign
against voter integrity and free and
fair elections that americans can have
competence in
and frankly they all owe an apology to
the people of georgia
they have an obligation to at least
acknowledge
basic fundamental truths instead of
needlessly dividing americans
even further with lies about this law